how can i spark myself and my business
up it's a question I came in from one of
my newsletter readers Susie Susie Thanks
for writing in she basically wrote in to
say she's been running this business she
said I feel I used to be on fire about
my business but I've gradually sunk into
a certain amount of apathy and blind
averageness so I want to learn how to
spark both my business and myself up
again Susie first of all I want you to
know that this is very common this isn't
something that a lot of entrepreneurs
talk about nobody really told me about
this but it's very common if you've had
a business for a while it's really
common to lose touch with it to lose the
passion to lose the excitement you need
to always be putting something new into
the company to stay motivated to see
excited what I found to be the best
result for me is to try to tie my
personal interest as much as possible
into the business so when I first
started this business it was all about
the famous entrepreneur stories because
that's how I learned I learned through
the success of other famous
entrepreneurs applied their strategies
to make it work for me and my whole
website was basically just me sharing
stories of famous entrepreneurs it
wasn't even about me I wasn't on there
was just writing and learning from these
successful entrepreneurs and it involved
I started to get other people to write
content for me I stopped loving the
writing you didn't want to write anymore
and that could have been the end of my
business I could have said you know this
this this sucks i don't i don't want to
do this anymore I'm bored I'm tired I'm
not motivate anymore so i had to find
something different so then i became
interested in getting other people to
write for me and I went out and I
recruited almost 8,000 people to write
from my website from business coaches
marketing consultants up to Donald Trump
and that was exciting for a while and
then that became born you know jump was
my big fish I wanted to go and get him
and I was really excited and the ones we
landed him people just arted to come on
their own because we had so much
momentum and I need to find another
thing to get me going and that could
have been the end of my business there
too right the next thing I started do
responding people on newsletters so it
created my newsletter people started
running in with questions and then I
quickly got bombarded again with with
questions and I was writing again and
and it was great for a while but then it
became too much and overwhelming and I
lost the passion for doing that so I
said with the videos and now I'm doing
the videos and I loved in the videos and
and so far so good I still love doing
the videos but if I lose interest in the
videos then I'll move on to do something
else and I keep trying to bring what I
believe in what I'm excited passion
about into my business the whole core of
everything i do is still about believing
in entrepreneurs and so wherever that
takes me I'm always growing my business
in different directions and the projects
that have worked out I either continue
by having somebody on my team do or by
by dropping and I move on to something
else you need to find what you are
strongly and deeply passionate about
personally and then bring that into your
business more and that may change and
evolve and then your business evolves
with it the more of a personal
connection you bring to your company the
more fun you're going to have the more
you're going to attract ideal customers
the more passion I'm gonna bring your
company the more money you're going to
make I got into salsa I make that part
of my business I talk about salsa
anything that you're interested in bring
it into your company and see how it
flies come up with the one thing that
you staying for for me it's believed I
see it in them in a lot of my videos
it's an uplifting message is something
that I strongly am and proud of its part
of me and whatever business I went into
it would still be about belief if I was
selling shoes it be about believe with
shoes without selling apartments would
be about believe with apartments and I
love helping entrepreneurs so everything
that I do and everybody on my team they
believe in believe and they believe in
entrepreneurs and we build out from
there so you've got to find the one
thing that is core to you not to your
business but to you and then bring that
into everything that you do
I know it can be hard especially if
you've done the same thing for years and
years and years and it gets frustrating
and you don't know how to break the
cycle and it's a habit now it's a habit
that you wake up every day and you're
not excited about what you're doing give
yourself some time to think free up your
schedule a little bit to focus on
something new that you can do even if
it's not related to your business
because you can find a way to bring it
in a quick example I am an investor in
the salsa dancing company I talked a
little bit about it when I first joined
salsa it wasn't to try to find my next
big opportunity if you're always looking
for the next big thing then you're
rarely going to find it because you're
forcing it you've got to let it come to
you I started salsa dancing if I looked
at as a business opportunity it wouldn't
have made any sense and I woulda quit it
because I was learning too late my steps
were ginormous I didn't understand the
music I couldn't commit to doing this on
a full-time basis there were so many
strikes against me didn't make sense why
would I get into salsa and had no
background in this and I would have quit
if I was just looking as a business
opportunity but I started doing it just
out of the the desire to explore to
learn more about myself and do something
different and I loved it and I fell in
love and now I'm an investor in the
business I'll teach some classes I'll DJ
three times a week at our events I love
doing it it's part of me now it became a
business opportunity because I wasn't
out there trying to ram every thought I
had into creating this new idea so
homework for you and everybody watching
number one is fine what score to you
find the one word the one thought the
one belief that means something to you
that that you read it and it gets you
excited one word and then try to bring
that into everything that you're doing
and number two if you're looking for new
opportunities you looking for something
different give yourself the time the
freedom the flexibility to go out and
try new things without having the
pressure of it having to be the next big
thing
if you do that success will be yours and
if you have any problems in this if you
want to help brainstorm this you you
want to share your philosophy with me on
your business I will help guide you
through the process because I want to
see you become successful believe those
you watching you like the video you know
the drill thumbs up below please and I
want to hear you have to think leave a
comment underneath let me know what you
think you have a question for your
business let me know below you want a
brainstorm with me put your thoughts
down below and i'll make a video
response thank you so much and I'll see
you soon